I think based on his shirt he's hoping
to interview you oh who's in the show oh
yeah it's me
but uh that's uh that's a good looking
shot
he's the man
I've worn this shirt what's funny is all
over the planet and it always gets a
reaction from people and I'm like I
can't believe I'm gonna I'm gonna get to
talk to you today and I will of course
wear this shirt but so when you take it
off could you just stand it up in the
corner
oh do you watch it every day
uh no it the uh the shirt gets washed
off and I'm not one of those people that
needs to wear it you know constantly oh
you don't okay got it Arnold uh if
someone has actually never seen I don't
know who this person is but if someone
has never seen anything you've done
before what is the first thing you'd
like them watching and why you know I
would tell them to watch football
in the same the simple reasons because I
not that I'm trying to Hype fupa now or
to say that it's coming out on you know
May 25th on his English this is totally
relevant in this case on Netflix what
I'm trying to tell you sit Netflix yeah
or did I forget Netflix yeah I forgot
Netflix sorry about that but in any case
what I'm saying is
it just has the whole combination of the
whole inventory so to speak of different
kind of styles of acting in there in one
show so there's the action in there
there's the intense Arnold in there
there's definitely Arnold in there
there's the generous and India and the
touristy kind of more sincere and all of
this kind of different angles and and
and and and and dimensions I think in
there so I think that's one of the
things that they can watch then if it
comes to kind of like something else
what should I watch
I think if they watch my uh
speech after the Insurrection on January
6th I think they would give them also
another idea of another Arnold you know
so this is all this different kind of
dimensions and I think that's what I
think Netflix is doing with the
documentary they're coming out of me is
to show all the different Islands Monica
you have worked with Tom Cruise you now
worked with Arnold have you thought
about playing the lottery
[Laughter]
think with my career right now that's a
good point but uh no yeah sure I'll buy
a ticket today just something I'm
thinking about yes one of the scenes I
enjoyed were it was a scene with you two
and the puppets and I was just thinking
how many takes did it did it take to
actually do that scene without laughing
so you could actually get a take we did
laugh a lot
um the funny thing about filming
anything is that you do so many
different takes and so many angles that
like I think by the 11th Hour we're like
does anyone still laughing because we've
been doing this over and over and over
again but I think it hopefully lasted
um
yeah I was I was breaking a lot I
couldn't believe how how high pitched
your voice
or how high pitched you really think I
sound
uh that was that was pretty funny and he
I tried to I was working on his voice
and I was asking him about you know I
was like will you say that the lines
that I say of yours in your voice and he
was like the thing about an Arnold
impression is that it doesn't actually
sound like me it is it's it's actually
turned into its own sort of thing and I
was watching videos watching other
people's impersonations Bill Hader has
probably the best one and I was like oh
yeah like it's almost its own it's taken
on its own character in a way if you
really like pound for pound or word for
word listen to an impression versus the
way he actually speaks it he doesn't
really quite sound the way the
impersonation sounds so from there I was
just sort of like okay have fun with
whatever version of it you want to I
have to say that I cracked up
and screwed up a lot of takes
because I remember the director got very
frustrated at one point
I had his puppet kisses kiss his soul
that well what happened was that that
made me feel good somehow
somehow Monica
was able to do every take a little
differently
and so there was always another stick in
there right that that made me surprised
and made me laugh and So eventually the
guy said to me the director said Hey
Arnold
let's settle down do you need a few
minutes because I would like to get one
take
way don't laugh because you're supposed
to be very serious and remember you're
in front of your psychiatrist your CIA
psychiatrists you know kind of advice
you're sitting in front of him he's
telling you this is a good way to get
rid of the hostilities that you have
taught to each other and blah blah blah
so he says I needed a serious scene
and so then we we didn't a few takes in
the serious way the nice thing was like
at the end of whatever what the part was
that was scripted they were like okay
and at the end there you can just be
yelling at each other and I felt like we
both were like okay and we took that and
ran with it and I don't think the door
slam was scripted
it was we had some fun with it for sure
what do you think soon to be fans of the
show would be surprised to learn about
the actual making of the show that every
episode was filmed in eight days
it was Yeah by eight to ten there were
some double units
when you went to school that's eight
days
an episode wasn't it
anyway so I'm gonna show you also eight
days because we don't want to fight here
in front of you not again but as soon as
you get off the screen
don't be worried there will just be a
little bit of screaming do some fact
checking and then she will be hitting me
again and all this kind of stuff it
would be elderly abuse
on that note I need to go I just want to
say I hope it's a big hit for you guys
and thank you for giving me your time
thank you so much